not what they normally do and they have
really stepped up and risen to the
occasion so I want to thank them let me
take you through some facts today
because we have some new facts changes
in circumstances that are not
encouraging and I want to make sure
people understand them and we react
accordingly the increase in the number
of cases continues unabated as a matter
of fact the rate of increase has gone up
we have the most sophisticated people
you can get doing projections on this
they've been studying projections from
China South Korea Italy places all
across this country and what they're now
seeing is that the rate of cases the
rate of new infections is doubling about
every three days that is a dramatic
increase in the rate of infection and
this whole discussion all along has been
how fast does the rate of increase
spread and can we slow the rate of
increase we're not slowing it and it is
accelerating on its own one of the
forecasters said to me we were looking
at a freight train coming across the
country we're now looking at a bullet
train because the numbers are going up
that quickly and the most challenging
point about the increasing numbers is
where the numbers will apex what is the
high point of the numbers and the apex
is the point where we have to be able to
manage to the capacity we had projected
the apex at about 110,000 hospital beds
and that's the number I've been talking
about the new projection suggests that
the number of hospitals the hospital
beds needed could be as high as 140,000
hospital beds so flatten the curve
flatten the curve we haven't flattened
the curve and the curve is actually
increasing that means the number of
hospital beds which is at 53,000 beds
3,000 ICU beds the anticipated need now
for the height of the curve is 140,000
hospital beds and approximately 40,000
intensive care unit beds those are
troubling and astronomical numbers and
as I mentioned our higher numbers than
had been previously projected we are
exercising all options as aggressively
as we can that rate of increase that
apex they project at this time could be
approximately 14 to 21 days away so not
only do we have a spike in the increase
when you spike the increase in cases it
accelerates the apex to a point where it
could be as close as 14 to 21 days we're
exercising all options we're doing
everything we can on every level to
quote-unquote slow the spread flatten
the curve we've closed businesses we've
reduced street density we had an issue
in New York City I spoke to mayor de
Blasio or spoke to City Council Speaker
Cory Johnson will have a plan that I
believe will be in place by noon today
and we have increased testing to the
highest level in the United States and
the highest per capita level on the
globe no one is testing more than we are
testing so in many ways we have
exhausted every option available to us
we've closed all the businesses we've
reduced the street density and we've
increased testing to the highest level
in the country we're also trying all the
new drug therapies the hydroxy Li
hydroxychloroquine which the president
speaks about and is optimistic about and
we hope for optimistic results also were
actually starting that today the
president and the FDA accelerated that
drug coming to New York so the hospitals
will start using that drug today the FDA
also authorized an experimental
procedure by the New York State
Department of Health where we the
Department of Health actually takes
plasma from people who are infected who
have the antibodies and we'll try
putting that plasma into a person who is
still struggling with a disease hoping
that the antibodies make a difference
we're also pursuing a new level of
testing which will test people's blood
to see if they have antibodies for the
corona virus which means they may have
been infected and resolved and never
knew it but if you had the corona virus
and resolved you now have an immunity to
the corona virus for some period of time
most experts suggest it's a significant
amount of time that would be very
important for us to know because these
are then healthcare workers who could go
back to work these are workers who could
return back to the private sector but
the inescapable conclusion is that the
rate of infection is going up it is
spiking the apex is higher than we
thought and the apex is sooner than we
thought that is a bad combination of
facts so slow the spread will still keep
doing everything we can but it is clear
that we must dramatically increase the
hospital capacity to meet
highest apex and we have to do it very
quickly again the apex could be here in
as little as 14 to 21 days and you're
talking about a very significant
logistical operational movement to
increase that number of hospital beds
and do everything that you need to do
related to the increase in hospital beds
there are three elements that are
necessary to increase the hospital
capacity first are obviously the
availability of the beds a bed without
staff is virtually useless and a bed and
a staff without the right equipment is
virtually useless so you have to
complete all three at the same time as
far as beds we have told the hospitals
I'm going to speak to every hospital
administrator today hospitals must
increase their capacity by 50% the goal
is to ask them to try to increase it by
100% remember we have 53,000 beds we
need 140,000 beds even if they did
increase it by 100% you'd only be it
about 100,000 beds you need 140,000 beds
emergency hospitals like the 1,000 bed
facility that's being built here will be
helpful the emergency hospitals that
were building at Westbury and Stony
Brook and it at the Westchester
Convention Center will be helpful but
they're nowhere near the number of beds
that we're going to need I have no
problem using the dormitories all across
our state campuses our CUNY campuses our
state university campuses I'm speaking
to hotel owners about taking over their
hotels to put patients in I will turn
this state upside down to get the number
of beds we need but we need the staff
for those beds and we're calling and
contacting all retirees in the
healthcare field work
all professionals in the healthcare
field whether or not they work in a
hospital they can work in an insurance
company a clinic or whatever but we want
to enlist as many staff as we can and as
many backup staff because healthcare
workers will get sick and this is going
to going to go on for weeks and you
can't ask a person to work for 14 days
consecutive or around-the-clock shift so
we'll need a backup reserve staff and
equipment equipment equipment masks PPEs
and ventilators and of those three the
greatest critical need our ventilators
now ventilators you say ventilators
nobody really knows what you're talking
about
the people who are going to come in the
people who will have acute needs these
are people who have our under
respiratory distress they need a
ventilator the ventilator will make the
difference between life and death
literally for these people this is a
piece of equipment that in the normal
course of business you don't have a need
for high levels of ventilators and our
hospital system has about three or four
thousand that has always met the need
this is a dramatic increase in the
number of ventilators that you need we
have been working around the clock
scouring the globe we've procured about
7,000 ventilators we need at a minimum
an additional 30,000 ventilators you
cannot buy them you cannot find them
every state is trying to get them other
countries are trying to get them the
capacity is limited their technical
pieces of equipment they're not
manufactured in two days or four days or
seven days or 10 days so this is a
critical and desperate need for
ventilators we're going so far as to try
an experimental procedure where we split
the ventilator we use one ventilator for
two patients it's difficult to perform
it's experimental
but at this point we have no alternative
so we're working on this experimental
application picture to hospital beds to
people in beds one ventilator between
the two of them but with two sets of
tubes to sense of pipes going to the two
patients again it's experimental
but mother necessity is the mother of
invention and we are working on this as
we speak
because life is options and we don't
have any other options there is no other
way for us to get these ventilators
we've tried everything else the only way
we can obtain these ventilators is from
the federal government period and this
two ways the federal government can do
it one is to use the federal defense
production Act there is a federal law
where the federal government can say to
manufacturers you must produce this
product I understand the federal
government's point that many companies
have come forward and said we want to
help and General Motors and Ford and
people are willing to get into the
ventilator business it does us no good
if they start to create a ventilator in
three weeks or four weeks or five weeks
we're looking at an apex of 14 days if
we don't have the ventilators in 14 days
it does us no good the federal defense
procurement Act can actually help
companies because the federal government
can say look I need you to go into this
business I will contract with you today
for X number of ventilators here is the
startup capital you need here's the
startup capital you need to hire workers
who do it around the clock but I need
the ventilators in 14 days
only the federal government has that
power and not to exercise that power is
inexplicable to me volunteerism is nice
and it is a beautiful thing and it's
nice that these companies are coming
forward and saying they want to help
that is not going to get us there and I
don't not for the life of me understand
the reluctance to use the federal
defense production Act also the federal
government has 20,000 ventilators or
there abouts in the federal stockpile
secretary a czar runs an agency called
HHS Health and Human Services I asked
the secretary look at the first word in
the title of the agency you run it is
health your first priority is health you
have 20,000 ventilators in the stock
pile release the ventilators to New York
how can we be in a situation where you
can have New Yorkers possibly dying
because they can't get a ventilator but
a federal agency saying I'm going to
leave the ventilators in the stock pile
I mean have we really come to that point
also we have to be smarter about the way
this is being done the federal
government has to prioritize the
resources look at where the problems are
across this nation California has 2800
cases Washington state 2,200 cases
Florida 1200 cases Massachusetts about
800 cases New York has 25,000 cases New
York has 25,000 cases it has 10 times
the problem that California has 10 times
the problem that Washington State has
you prioritize resources and your
activity and your actions to where they
are needed and New York you are
looking at a problem that is of a
totally different magnitude and
dimension the the problem is the volume
dealing with 2000 cases is one thing
2000 cases frankly we could deal with in
this building with the capacity that
we're providing we have 25,000 cases we
need the federal help and we need the
federal help now also there is a smart
way to do this
deploy the ventilators around the
country as they are needed different
regions have different curves of the
infection New York is the canary in the
coal mine New York is going first we
have the highest and the fastest rate of
infection what happens to New York is
going to wind up happening to California
and Washington state in Illinois it's
just a matter of time we're just getting
there first deal with the issue here
deployed the resources deployed the
ventilators here in New York for our
apex and then after the apex passes here
once we're past that critical point
deploy the ventilators through the other
parts of the country where they are
needed I'm not asking for 20,000
ventilators and they stay in New York
and they live in New York and change
their residence as soon as we finish
with the ventilators then you move them
to the next part of the country that has
the critical problem and then after that
region hits its apex then you move to
the next part of the country that has
its critical problems I will take
personal responsibility for transporting
the 20,000 ventilators anywhere in this
country that they want once we are past
our apex but don't leave them sitting in
a stockpile and say well we're gonna
wait to see how we Alec
take them across the country that's not
how this works they're not simultaneous
apexis they are a curve that is
individual to that region deploy to that
region address that region and then move
on to the next and I'm not only talking
about ventilators we get past the apex
we get over that curve that curve starts
to come down we get to a level where we
can handle it
I'll send ventilators I'll send health
care workers
I'll send our professionals who dealt
with it and who know all around the
country and that's how this should be
done you know it's gonna be on a
different calendar it's gonna be a
different sequence let's help each other
New York because New York is first and
then after New York and after the curve
breaks in New York let's all rush to
whoever second and then it's all rush to
whoever is third and let's learn from
each other and help each other I want to
make a point on the president's point
about the economy and public health I
understand what the president is saying
this is unsustainable that we closed
down the economy and we continue to
spend money that there is no doubt about
that no one is gonna argue about that
but if you ask the American people to
choose between public health and the
economy then it's no contest no American
is going to say accelerate the economy
at the cost of human life because no
American is going to say how much a life
is worth job one has to be save lives
that has to be the priority and there's
a smarter approach to this we don't have
to choose between the two you can
develop a more refined public health
strategy that is also an economic
strategy what do I mean by that
our public health strategy was a blunt
instrument what we said at a moment of
crisis is isolate everyone close the
schools close the colleges send everyone
home isolate everybody in their home in
truth that was not the most refined
public strategy why because it wasn't
even smart frankly to isolate younger
people with older people but at that
moment we didn't have the knowledge we
needed to act that's what we did you can
now start to refine that public health
strategy you can start to say look the
lower risk individuals do not need to be
quarantined and they shouldn't be
quarantined with an older person who
they may be transferring it to people
who are recovered you test them you test
the antibodies you find out that they've
resolved themselves of the virus and I
believe once we get that test you're
going to find hundreds of thousands of
people who have had the corona virus and
resolved once they resolved they can go
back to work develop that test it's in
testing now once they're resolved let
them go back to work let the younger
people go back to work let the recovered
people go back to work it's even better
for the older vulnerable people who
you're trying to protect and then ramp
up the economy with those individuals so
you're refining your public health
strategy and at the same time you're
restarting your economy those two can be
consistent if done intelligently restart
the economy with our younger recovered
tested workers don't make us choose
between a smart health strategy and a
smart economics dress
we can do both and we must do both it's
not the economy or public health it's
restarting the economy and protecting
public health it is both
but I understand restarting the economy
the crisis today focus on the crisis at
hand focus on the looming wave of cases
that is about to break in 14 days that
has to be the priority and that is
hospital capacity and that is about
providing hospital beds providing staff
and providing equipment and providing
PPE and providing ventilators coming
back to that number of 30,000 and
needing federal action to address it now
if the federal government said today I
will deploy all 20,000 ventilators it
will take us two weeks to get those
ventilators into hospitals and to create
ICU beds and to locate the staff so
there is no time to waste the time to do
this is is now FEMA is sending us 400
ventilators I saw on the news this
morning we are sending 400 ventilators
to New York
400 ventilators I need 30,000
ventilators you want a pat on the back
for sending 400 ventilators what are we
gonna do for 400 with 400 ventilators
when we need 30,000 ventilators you're
missing the magnitude of the problem and
the problem is defined by the magnitude
these are the numbers from today you can
see our testing rate is now over 90,000
people who have been tested that's the
highest rate of testing in the country
and per capita on the globe we did
12,000 new tests since yesterday number
of positive cases state of New York
25,000 665
4700 new cases of those tested you see
the entire state county by county more
and more counties are being covered we
have 3000 people currently who are
hospitalized
we have 750 six people in ICU units the
ICU units are the ventilated units
that's 23 percent of the
hospitalizations that's the problem as
the number of cases go up the number of
people in hospital beds goes up the
number of people who need an ICU bed and
a ventilator goes up and we cannot
address that increasing curve again you
look at the number of cases in the
country you'll see that New York is an
outlier in the number of cases it's not
even close what is happening in New York
is not a New York phenomenon right
people in New York don't have a
different immune system than other
Americans it's not higher in New York
because we are New Yorkers it's higher
in New York because it started here
first because we have global travelers
coming here first because we have more
density than most places but you will
see this in cities all across the
country and you will see this in
suburban communities all across the
country we are just a test case we are
just the test case and that's how the
nation should look at it look at us
today where we are today you will be in
three weeks or four weeks or five weeks
or six weeks we are your future and what
we do here will chart the course course
for what we do in your city and in your
community I'm not asking you to help in
New York just to help New York I'm
asking you to help me
York to help yourselves let's learn how
to do it right and let's learn how to do
it right here and let's learn how to act
as one nation and let's learn how to act
as one nation here and we learn the
lesson here we will save lives in your
community I promise you that we're
delivering supplies that we've been able
to purchase today in New York City has
had a critical problem I spoke to mayor
de Blasio he's right
he had a critical problem on PPE gowns
masks etc the equipment we're bringing
today will resolve that immediate need
there'll be no hospital in the city of
New York who will say today their nurses
their doctors can't get equipment and
we're addressing that need not just for
New York City but also for Long Island
and Westchester we have acquired
everything on the market there is to
acquire we've had a full team purchasing
from companies all across this globe
buying everything that can be purchased
and we're bringing that here to
distribute to New York City Long Island
Westchester because that is the greatest
need this number of supplies will take
care of our immediate need it does not
take care of the need going forward
three four five six weeks the burn rate
on this equipment is very very high I
can't find any more equipment it's not a
question of money I don't care what
you're willing to pay you just can't
find the equipment now but this will
take care of the immediate need I don't
want our health care workers who are
doing God's work they are doing God's
work can you imagine the nurses who
leave their homes in the morning who
kissed their children goodbye
go to a hospital put on gowns deal with
people who have the coronavirus they're
thinking all day long oh my god I hope I
don't get this oh my god I hope I don't
get this and bring this home to my
children you want to talk about
extraordinary individuals extraordinary
and it's the nurses and the doctors and
the health care workers it's the police
officers who show up every day and go
out there and walk into a situation that
they don't even know what they're
walking into
and it's the firefighters and it's the
transportation workers and it's the
people who are running the grocery
stores and the pharmacies and providing
all those essential services most of us
are in our home hunkered down
worried they're worried and they're
going out there every day despite their
fear despite their fear overcoming their
fear and not for their family they're
doing it for your family when you see
them on the street when you see them in
a hospital please just say thank you and
smile and say I know what you're doing
what happens all these facts all these
numbers am i strong and my language visa
v the federal government yes I am but
what happens at the end of the day what
does it all mean
that's what people want to know what
does it all mean what it all means is
what we said it all means the first day
this started the first day I went before
the people of New York State and I said
I'm going to tell you the truth I'm
going to tell you the facts the way I
know it those facts have not changed
those facts are not going to change this
is not a new situation we've watched
this through China there are hundreds
thousands of cases 80% will self
resolved
that's why experts say to me tens of
thousands or hundreds of thousands of
people have had the virus didn't know
they had it and resolved that's why we
have to get that test that shows you had
the virus you because you have the
antibodies and you did resolve and once
we do that that's how you get the
economy back to work that's how you get
the back up health care workers but 80%
of Ghana self resolved 20% of them going
to need hospitals it's not about that
it's about a very small group of people
in this population who are the most
vulnerable they are older they have
compromised immune systems they are HIV
positive or they have emphysema or they
have an underlying heart condition or
they have bad asthma or they're
recovering from cancer those are the
people who are going to be vulnerable to
the mortality of this disease and it is
only 1% or 2% of the population but then
why all of this because it's 1% or 2% of
the population
it's lives
it's grandmothers and grandfathers and
sisters and brothers and you start to
see the cases on TV it's a 40 year old
woman who recovered from breast cancer
but had a compromised immune system and
four children at home that's what this
is about it's about our vulnerable
population I called the executive order
that I passed Matilda's law my mother
it's about my mother it's about my
mother it's about your mother
it's about your loved one and we will do
anything we can to make sure that they
are protected
again keeping it in perspective Johns
Hopkins 387,000 cases studied 16,000
deaths on three hundred and eighty seven
thousand one hundred thousand recoveries
worldwide 268,000 pending last point it
is about the vulnerable it's not about
ninety-five percent of us it's about a
few percent who are vulnerable that's
all this is about bring down that
anxiety bring down that fear bring down
that paranoia
it's not about ninety-five percent of us
and we're going to get through it
because we are New York and because
we've dealt with a lot of things and
because we are smart you have to be
smart to make it in New York and we are
resourceful and we we are showing how
resourceful we are and because we are
united and when you were united there is
nothing you can't do and because we are
New York tough we are tough you have to
be tough this place makes you tough but
it makes you tough in a good way we're
going to make it because I Love New York
and I Love New York
because New York loves you New York
loves all of you black and white and
brown and Asian and short and tall and
gay and straight New York loves everyone
that's why I love New York
it always has it always will and at the
end of the day my friends even if it is
a long day and this is a long day love
wins always and it will win again
through this virus thank you
the preliminary plan Zack is it will
backfill hospitals you take the
situation we're looking at we need
ventilators we need ICU beds those can
only really be created in the hospital
but then you're gonna have to move
people out of a hospital where do you
put them
this facility 1,000 beds can backfill
from a hospital this facility also has
acute care capacity but we're not
anticipating that we do acute care here
we're anticipating that it's a backfill
for the hospital beds
yeah my mother is not expendable and
your mother is not expendable and our
brothers and sisters are not expendable
and we're not going to accept the
premise that human life is disposable
and we're not going to put a dollar
figure on human life the first order of
business is save lives period whatever
it costs
now I also don't believe it's an
either/or
I believe you can have an intelligent
refined public health strategy they talk
about risk stratification you can have
people go to work you can test people
and find out that they are resolved from
the virus let them go back to work
you're gonna have younger people go back
to work you can have an economic startup
strategy that is consistent with the
public health strategy it's smart it's
complicated it's sophisticated but
that's what government is supposed to do
right that whole concept of developed
government policy and program you can do
both but not in a clumsy ham-handed way
right well we'll just sacrifice old
people they're old people anyway and the
old get left behind
what is this some modern Darwinian
theory of natural selection you can't
keep up so the the band is gonna leave
you behind we're gonna move on and if
you can't keep up well then you just
fall by the wayside of life god forbid
tomorrow
yeah yeah people say people say people
say politicians say yeah I look at
actions not words they're doing the
supplies here's my question where are
they where are the ventilators where are
the gowns where's the pee Pease where
are the masks where are they where are
they if they're doing it and by the way
Peter Navarro well we want to work with
companies fine work with companies when
what the defense procurement Act was
about the country needed materials to go
to war they didn't when we went to war
we didn't say any company I didn't want
to build a battleship horse to build a
battleship maybe a couple of you guys
could get together and build a
battleship maybe a couple of you guys
could get together and build us some
missiles maybe you think anybody want to
build a plane you know we're gonna need
planes and they're sending planes at us
and they're dropping bombs anybody want
to do that that's not how you did it
president said it's a war it is a war
well then act like it's a war and it's
not anti-business nobody's talking about
change the governmental philosophy by
the way the businesses would welcome it
I speak to the businesses you know what
they say I'll do it but I need startup
capital I can't turn my factory
overnight into a ventilator
manufacturing company I have to buy
equipment I have to find personnel I
have a lot of startup capital will you
give me the startup capital will you
give me an order that says if I go
through all this you will buy X number
of units it's actually a pro-business
mentality not an anti business mentality
this is a false distinction well we
don't want to tell business what to do
that's our philosophy we don't want to
tell business what to do you know what
business wants they want to make money
that's what they want they want to put
people to work they want to open their
factory they were
make money let them open the factory
make money help them do that by ordering
the supplies you need it's a war you're
right
say Zack you're building battleships
here's your contract god bless you
that's how the that's what the defense
procurement act was all about and at the
rate they are going it is not happening
FEMA says we're sending 400 ventilators
really what am I going to what am I
going to do with 400 ventilators when I
need 30,000 you pick the 26,000 people
who are going to die because you only
sent 400 ventilators you have to ask the
federal government what do I know I
don't know their answer is we don't need
to do it because companies are coming
forward who want to do it and by the way
I am sure that is true it's just the
timeline doesn't work I don't need
ventilators in six months and I don't
need ventilators in five months four
months or three months and by the way
California is not going to need
ventilators in six months it is now so
you're asking a business to produce what
is a sophisticated piece of electronic
equipment uh ventilator and to do it in
14 days that's an enormous undertaking
they can't do that on a voluntary basis
if you use the defense procurement Act
EPA then you say I'll pay for it I'll
give you the startup capital I'll fine
you buying the equipment I'll fund you
hiring workers otherwise it doesn't work
on a normal business timetable and the
businesses want to know look if I go
through all of
somebody has to buy 40,000 ventilators
you know ventilator is on average twenty
twenty-five thousand dollars per
ventilator this is an expensive item
nobody's going to build 40,000
ventilators unless they know someone is
buying 40,000 ventilators and that's
what the federal government can give
them with a DPA I buy 40,000 ventilators
caveat they have to be here in 21 days
and then use them here we hit a pecs
first I will transport them anywhere you
want in the country I'm not asking you
to give us 40,000 ventilators out in
front item address the curve here and
then that curve is going to be going all
across the country you hear what I'm
saying here today you're going to have
the governor of California several weeks
from now saying the same thing you're
going to have the governor of Illinois
saying the same thing the governor of
the state of Washington saying the same
thing do it right here we're just the
first case we're just the first template
do it right here and then we'll move the
goods I'll move the professionals
I'll move the doctors and the nurses who
can say we can teach you how to do this
because we went through it we saw this
in New York we can actually help one
another that's smart that's right that's
the American Way
I spoke to the mayor this morning I
spoke to the mayor yesterday
whatever need he has will figure out how
to address you have a lot of situations
that develop here that just nobody no
one could have expected right these are
uncharted waters for all of us but
that's why I said resourceful smart
would quick on our feet we're agile
what's the problem we'll figure out how
to solve it we'll do it together I
haven't even thought about its act
multi-part question there are two
different types of facilities here one
is an emergency hospital for separate
components 250 each equaling 1,000 in an
emergency hospital that could be used
for acute care there's a second facility
if you will which is 1,000 beds it's a
lower level of medical care for people
who don't need as intense service but
let me ask the generals Pat is that you
want to comment on that pad or general
shields the first the first phase of the
build-out is the thousand beds from
Health and Human Services that comes in
with the kit wheel a medical
professionals over the top of that we go
to Phase two we continue to build out
bed capacity so that we can provide a
little higher level of care potentially
as we move forward but we have an
immediate level and then there's a third
phase that we continue to build our beds
in the facility to get to the capacity
that the governor is getting after which
does not address the entire number but
starts in that path and then the other
strategies to go along with it so we
expect in the end to be above 2000
but the basic number is a thousand and a
thousand and we're working towards being
above that number by the time we're done
dressing it out yeah let me I'm sorry
the the fork she's me one second
the four the hospitals will be staffed
by federal medical personnel for the 250
bed for 250 bed facilities the one
thousand about three hundred and twenty
medical federal personnel in true
they're working on it now you don't have
a hard answer now enter they're working
on it now they're developing it it's a
fairly simple test I'm not a medical
it's only testing your blood for those
antibodies right so it's a fairly simple
test I don't have an answer but I can
get you an estimate but let me just
because these all come back to the same
point the reason I've always said to New
Yorkers relax is because this is not a
major issue for 95 96 97 98 percent of
the population it's only those
vulnerable people 1 or 2 percent of the
population this conversation about the
economy your question blunt and jarring
in its bluntness well if we're only
talking about one or two percent of the
population and they're old and they're
vulnerable and they're sick anyway well
then why stop the economy how much are
we paying for this 1 or 2 percent
they're older vulnerable they're going
to die anyway why stop the train for the
one or two percent it's the same point
that I've been saying on 90% of the
people gonna be fine don't worry unless
you're in that vulnerable category and
then take a high level of precaution but
we're not willing to sacrifice that 1 or
2% we're not willing to do that that is
not who we are it's not what we are it's
not what we believe we are going to
fight every way we can to save every
life that we can because that's what I
think it means to be an American I know
that's what it means to be a New Yorker
so I'm not going to leave any stone
unturned until we can make sure everyone
is protected
that's what I was trying to communicate
by calling it Matilda's law right that's
why I give it my mother's name she
didn't want me to give it her name she's
a little annoyed of me but I wanted to
personalize it for people that's what
we're told yes it's only one or two
percent don't worry go live your life
it's only one or two percent but the one
or two percent is Mathilda and Sally and
Jane and Sara and your uncle and my
uncle and they are precious and I'm not
giving up I am NOT giving up
no look if lightning strikes look I
agree first of all I agree with the
president try everything you can I agree
he said he had heard good things about
that drug combination so had I I said
send it to me I will use it first as
soon as you sent it to me I will use it
he sent it to me I'm using it today not
plastic if it works great great but
we're talking about two weeks here if it
doesn't work and by the way even if it
does work you're still gonna need the
beds for people to be on a ventilator
while you give them the drug even if it
turns out that it winds up saving their
lives you don't get around needing the
hospital beds and needing the
ventilators I have to go to work guys
thank you very much thank you
I would have to check exactly what
projects they're doing I don't know but
if you tell me what projects I will
check thank you
be safe